the same standard should apply to me as
applies to everyone on Twitter just as
it is on positive or negative now the
another thing that that a lot of
traditional journalists don't like is
they don't like being put on the same
platform as the average citizen they
don't like their voice being it's the
same they're pretty mad about that there
are several news organizations who don't
like your push for democratization and
what they believe is the devaluing of
the badges because they were
differentiated is that just a moment in
time no that's deliberate I think it's
very important for to to elevate citizen
journalism uh I think it's very
important to hear the voice of the
people the actual voice of the people
not the filtered voice of the people and
let the people choose the narrative and
let the people determine the truth
and not five editors in Chiefs of major
Publications this does get us to that
starting point of the elites versus the
people Elon Musk has done in Twitter is
actually quite Brave